no hay fugas radiactivas así lo confirmó
el director general de la oea rafael
grossi explicando a la prensa que el
ataque en la central de esa polilla
atribuido a las fuerzas rusas no golpeó
los reactores indicó su voluntad de
viajar a ucrania
football federation le he indicado tanto
a la federación rusa con más gran ya en
disponibilidad para viajar a chernóbil
tan pronto como sea posible para que
estos siete pilares nunca más se vean
amenazados possible soltar tis se den
crisol peters art never again compromise
rusia rechaza toda responsabilidad en lo
ocurrido
sin embargo anoche en el territorio
adyacente a la central eléctrica el
régimen nacionalista de kiev intentó
llevar a cabo una monstruosa provocación
el 4 de marzo alrededor de las 2 de la
mañana durante una patrulla del
territorio vigilado adyacente a la
planta de energía nuclear de sap orilla
una patrulla móvil de la guardia
nacional fue atacada por un grupo de
sabotaje ucraniano para el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr silencio rusia es un
terrorista nuclear triple es necesario
un refuerzo inmediato de las sanciones
contra el estado terrorista nuclear es
necesario el cierre inmediato de los
cielos sobre ucrania porque solo esto
puede garantizar que rusia no atacará al
menos con misiles y bombas de aire en
las instalaciones nucleares un bomba o
abdomen abierto la situación llegó a
reino unido a pedir una reunión de
urgencia del consejo de seguridad de la
onu
no sólo es peligroso para ucrania y los
rusos es peligroso para europa y es
jugar con fuego realmente está más allá
de cualquier cosa que tenga que ver con
la lógica o la necesidad y nosotros en
los términos más enérgicos posibles le
pedimos que se detenga
oscar stop that la invasión rusa ucrania
que entra en su noveno día es tema
principal de la cumbre de cancilleres de
la otan y de la unión europea reunidos
en bruselas